this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice hi i'm dave ramsey your host this
is your show america common sense for
your dollars and cents open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five having done this show now for 25
plus years coming up on 30 years i um
i have been amazingly blessed to get to
meet some of the more iconic people in
this wonderful town of nashville
that i live in and i've gotten to call
many of them friends and so we had some
of that happen today some of our friends
have dropped in
uh the iconic group the isaacs if you
don't know who the isaacs are they are
in the gospel music hall of fame last
week our friend ricky skaggs invited
them to join the grand ole opry and they
have sold millions and millions of
articles and they've got their 52nd gma
dove nomination for their 2020 album
songs of the times uh just yesterday as
a matter of fact and a couple of the
isaacs we couldn't get everybody in here
and it kind of was a little bit of a
family feud as to who got to come here
sure was but uh we were hanging out at
john richards the other night uh for the
uh candace owen and uh ben shapiro
archive come to nashville he had an
event welcome welcoming them and you
guys gotta you ladies get up and sing
with your brother and it's just
absolutely amazing as always and we got
the talking there and then we that led
to us saying hey they have a new album
coming out let's talk about it so thanks
for coming by so uh becky and sonia are
with us of the isaac's welcome thank you
so much we're honored to be here we love
you so we love you guys we're so glad to
have you very cool stuff so um the album
came out yesterday and you guys are this
i keep calling you guys but most of your
ladies but you are uh are traditionally
gospel
that's what we all know you for in
nashville uh but the album is charting
on the country yes so this album is
actually not a gospel record it's the
first
uh the first album the isaacs have ever
released that's not gospel it is i mean
they're great songs life songs love
songs story songs and we've always
included those type of songs on our
records in the past and we've always
done things like the grand ole opry and
you know other secular venues uh but
this is the first time we've ever done a
whole album of just those type of songs
and so it really does have a place in
that secular market in the country
market and so we were surprised when uh
this weekend we were watching the
numbers and uh it ticked on up to number
seven in the country download charts and
all of itunes and number 20 in all
genres of music so that's pretty
exciting for a little local group yeah a
little local group yeah she says humbly
the american face is the album it was
released august 13. it's a 12 song
collection split between new material
classic covers bluegrass country rhythm
and blues folk contemporary which you
got you can sing anything i mean
it's not your first ride on this cabbage
truck so you can you guys can put
together a harmony on almost anything so
i'm not surprised to see the crossover
here and and the success with it very
very strong so your mom lily is a great
american story yes she is we are living
the american dream and it all began with
her
she uh her parents are both polish
jewish holocaust survivors
and they were in the camps in uh poland
and germany she was born in a french
army relief camp in germany after my
grandparents were liberated from the
holocaust
and uh you know they moved to america
when she was two years old and she
became an american citizen via ellis
island uh when she was nine years old
and you know she had a hard life her
parents started over here with nothing
and they built a life working hard and
believing in the american dream and she
never would have dreamed all those years
ago that she'd be singing gospel music
for most of her life and then to be
asked to be members of the grand ole
opry
no one could have ever anticipated that
sort of a life for her but she is an
amazing woman yes she is always fun to
talk to lily yeah she's gonna she wanted
to be here but i i kind of like mom i'm
the baby so i had to pull the baby card
today oh okay well she's here she's in
the studio she's getting to hear us brag
on her so it's good but so 35 years ago
the isaacs were started and actually 50
years ago
they probably need to update that bio
mom and dad started singing 50 years ago
our dad's the baby child of 17 children
who his parents were pentecostal
preachers his father was a preacher
there were farmers back in the hills and
the haulers of eastern kentucky and it
was music that brought mom and dad
together in
new york city gerdy's folk city in
greenwich village where a lot of people
were discovered like peter paul and mary
and different ones and so they they were
dad was singing bluegrass mom was
singing folk rock music and they were at
this comes out of a pentecostal family
ends up on the hippie scene right
right this is fun yeah there's got to be
a little story here our mom thought he
was jewish with a name like isaac
isaac's how can you not think that he
was not jewish
jewish boy she didn't bother to tell her
any different until she'd already fallen
in love with him
so they so they you know they were in
new york singing together and then uh my
my dad's brother his closest in age was
killed in a car accident um and so after
that they they both went to his funeral
service which was at a church and they
both opened their hearts to receive um
the lord
and that was the beginning of the
isaac's 50 years ago 50 years they've
been singing yeah yeah that's pretty
impressive and of course ben your
brother sings with you guys with you all
now he aggravates and sings with us
against
as a musician would leave the band the
isaacs are the original isaac's our
parents um mom and dad would see the
talent in us they would set an
instrument in the in the living room and
darris to touch it and that's how we
learn how to play music
and you know dad would put a base in
ben's hand and next thing you know when
the bass player left ben would step up
and sonia started playing mandolin
mandolin when she was nine and i was 11
when i started playing the guitar and so
we've just slowly
become who we are but you can see the
influence of the bluegrass side of our
father and the folky rock side the
hippie movement of our mom which
explains a lot about this record we've
done a lot of records in the past that
have honored the bluegrass side of our
father
but this record kind of leans a little
bit more towards an americana folky
style and you know we give our mom a
hard time she still has the feathers she
kept those and she was at shea stadium
for the first time when the beatles
performed and she went to woodstock yeah
woodstock yeah ask her she still
remembers woodstock but um yeah we're
just like a we've been called the little
gospel chipmunks we've been called uh
kosher hillbillies uh jubilees yeah
willie's
hebrews we're all mixed up i'm a year
younger than her and my brother's three
years older than me so
from the moment we could talk we could
sing harmony full part harmony so um yes
you're in cheap labor that's right
mom put you to work and have to pay you
that other bass player you had to pay
them but you'll have to you'll really
appreciate this from the time i've been
a child i had the envelope program that
you talk about and i would write down
what it is and i would put the cash in
there and by the time i got married and
so i still i still do some of your
amazing
most of what you talk about so well i'm
honored all right sonya and becky isaacs
the new album is the american face it
released last week charting already on
the country charts again 52nd dove
nomination gospel music hall of fame and
last week inducted into the grand ole
opry so i want to fire this tune before
we run up on the break so the audience
gets to hear it this is one of the
singles from the album
stop paying your overpriced wireless
provider and switch to pure talk they
use the same network as the larger
providers for much less for just 30 a
month get unlimited talk text and six
gigs of data with no contract the
average family saves over 70 dollars a
month by switching to pure top just go
to puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
pure talk simply smarter wireless
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
america open phones at triple eight
eight two five five
two two five you jump in we'll talk
about your life and your money max is
gonna start off this hour in knoxville
hey max welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me certainly
how can i help
well uh
my wife we're looking to
sell our farm
here coming up uh here in a short time
and with our expected uh conservative
members projected to profit after we pay
off the mortgage on it and the capital
gains
uh it's going to be around 550 000 maybe
six hundred thousand i hate it when that
happens
yeah wow yeah it's a good problem to
have so
uh our question is
what should we look to do we're working
our way through the baby steps four five
six uh with our kids college funds etc
and retirements
we've already maxed out the retirements
for the for this year um
and we have 529 plans but
only have about
five thousand dollars in each of the
three plans uh for each of our three
young children
but uh our idea was maybe to front load
those 529 plans
uh off the bat and get that
done on the front end so not to
contribute anymore yeah i like that one
less thing to worry about right
yeah um what is a projected we were
looking you know that their colleges in
roughly 16 years from now we were
looking maybe
a target of say a hundred and fifty
thousand dollars each kid
uh when they get to that age
uh is that a
where do you get your projected numbers
from of what college may or may not be
then well of course god only knows right
i mean there's no um
there's no way to know the the inflation
rate is about 12
on tuition i'm sorry about seven percent
on tuition
um the inflation rate on everything else
runs average about four
so um if you want to use a seven percent
inflation rate you got about a twelve
thousand dollar ten thousand dollar
average in-state school tuition right
now you could run that out so it's 40
grand right now
plus uh plus room and board plus seven
percent inflation rate and you can sit
down with your financial advisor and
project that for the number of years
you've got left and then do front load
those but it won't take 10 or 15 grand
out of this 500 you still got a lot of
money left after you do that
okay
um and then there the other the only
debt we have left um
on us is our
uh
home mortgage
in which we owe roughly 600 000 on that
yeah um what's your household income
uh 300 000 a year man you're just
killing it way to go dude this is all
good news all around they're blessed
yeah very blessed for sure i love the
idea of you paying off this house i mean
you're saying the kids got they got 16
more years before they head to college
correct i mean with that with that kind
of income you've got 16 years to invest
i don't see anything wrong with paying
off the house
if you it sounds like you could do it
once you sell the farm would you have
enough
yes we would have enough we'd have rough
i mean if we took just the conservative
numbers what we think for profit after
this we could definitely just pay off
just the house we have
you know i have other taxable accounts
that
um if needed you know we could draw some
money out of but we were more longer
just monthly checks we would just finish
whatever is needed yeah um so because
your income because your income's so
ridiculously wonderful i'd write a check
i'm with george i'd rather check out of
the farm pay off the house that puts you
at baby step seven you have addressed
baby step five i'm not skipping a baby
step because you've got money in there
for college then you just take 10 20
grand out of your income and you can
still front load over the next few
months or six months or something decide
to front load those 529 plans the rest
of the way so sit down with your smart
investor pro or your advisor calculate
what you need to take out of your 300k
income and do that and i'm with george
now that we got a little deeper into
this uh yeah let's pay off that house i
mean just if the kids are half as smart
as you are i think they're going to be
just fine and it's going to come down to
college choice and what their dreams are
but you guys have so much time ahead of
you and you've done so well i love the
idea of you not having a house payment
and making 300 grand
the kids are going to school debt-free
i'm just going to say right now i'm not
worried about it yeah yeah i think
you're going to be okay because you're
going to have plenty of money even if
it's not in the 529 plan you're going to
be very very wealthy
with this income and no debt payments at
all and your obvious bent towards doing
things on purpose with money that's
that's a big deal here and so very well
done man touchdown
congratulations this is very very cool
i'm impressed you know when you said
that it made me laugh i hadn't thought
about this guy in 20 years but i knew
this old guy
and he was kind of an old
uh
you know when you get old you either get
happier or grouchier
and this guy was the grouchy one right
oh boy and he's like ramsay i'm trying
to make so much money that no matter how
dumb my kids are they can't spin through
it and i'm discovering that it's not
possible
[Laughter]
that's what i thought of when you said
that's good half they're half as smart
as you
that's all you need you can't make
enough money to outspend really truly
stupid children
we know the story of the prodigal son
dave you know you can spend a lot of
money really quickly if you're dumb
enough
all right dawn is with us dawns in
indianapolis hi dawn how are you
hey i'm doing great thanks for taking my
call sure what's up i'm going to be
well i'm going to do 50 next week and
i'm just i'm really struggling with the
state of the world and the division and
how to navigate you know i'm working
working
entering on the side i've chosen to be
unvaccinated as a personal choice i just
feel like the world is closing in
i'm on every dollar i've been following
you for four years
i was very hardcore and
less 18 months ago i went through a
divorce because of
um financial infidelity
lying about stuff i thought we were
paying off things that we want so i kind
of had to catch my breath and i started
doing davish
and i'm just
i i almost feel like only 16 000 of debt
but i almost feel like i just want to
like start saving my money and just
feel like there's some
peace in the world i don't i don't know
so i just wanted some encouragement or
to get some advice
it's not peace in the world that's the
problem it's peace in you
okay you got
you got hammered girl you gotta hurt
and i'll i you know listening to you it
sounds like you're emotionally holding
your breath
like you're just trying to hold on and
just not cry
um and i've been there i know how it
feels um
but you've been through personal
emotional trauma
this year
i have but i'm strong i know you're
strong i wasn't accusing you of
collapsing
i was just accusing you of being human
but i feel like i should go out and get
like another job or do some stuff and
this part of me just wants to stay home
and just get this debt paid off and just
just okay i don't know
so why don't you put yourself on a plan
that has a more reasonable pace
and gives you some
margin to heal
because you're wounded
would that be okay would that be okay
to just absolutely let's just take your
super supergirl cape off and hang it up
in the closet for a minute
okay
and let's just let's just go okay i'm
gonna take a year
and breathe
because i've just been through hell you
guys were married a long time
weren't you
we did and we were i thought we were
almost to the end
of our plan and we paid off over 12 20
000 worth of debt
only to find out that we didn't and
there was 60 000 that i had a divorce
and split and take with me
yeah you'll be okay though
you know how to do this
it's having the gas in your tank to do
it
right
that's true yes how long were you
married 20 plus
yes 23. yeah
i mean this is this
as uh as our friend dr john baloney says
it you need to take a little time and
grieve this
what do you think george absolutely don
and you you said you're turning 50 right
i am yeah i think you're here i think
you ought to have one hellacious
birthday party you need to party don you
got a lot of life ahead of you you're
just getting started it's half time
start dreaming again get some big
balloons
it's half time
throw a fit
stir up a ruckus
give yourself a little time kiddo you're
going to be all right
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt free stage alec
and carolyn are with us hey guys how are
you good how are you how are you better
than i deserve welcome where do you guys
live we're from pittsburgh all right
welcome to nashville and all the way
down here to do a debt-free screening
absolutely very cool how much did you
pay off we paid off uh about 63 000 it
was 16 months 16 months and your range
of income during that time yeah when we
started our income was about 75 000 and
then by the time we paid our debt off
our income's gone up to close to 90 000
but that doesn't include any of our side
hustles oh okay what do y'all do for a
living
i work for a distributor of air
compressors i'm a school teacher awesome
what was the most lucrative
side hustle
um i i have two that are pretty good um
i in college i detailed cars at a
dealership
and that taught me a lot about you know
just detailing and that kind of stuff
but kind of a nice business doing that
and then i also have been very fortunate
to be uh an ice hockey coach for little
kids for like a youth hockey program in
pittsburgh and that's been very very
helpful so um that's a paid gig oh yeah
yep yeah it's like a triple a driving
award when i did it the parents just
bitched at it
yeah it's uh it's awesome i am very very
fortunate awesome wow very cool good for
you guys that's neat all right so what
kind of debt was the 63 000 it was
mostly me uh i had a car a cell phone in
my student loans all right and i had a
little bit left on my student loans yeah
so how long have you all been married we
got married on uh june of 2020 so a
little over a year oh okay so you
started this before marriage yeah we
started in i think like march of 2020
like right i think we had our first two
classes right before the pandemic
straight into pan dammit yeah so we had
the rest of our panda or our rest of our
uh first of our class uh over zoomed
during the pandemic engagement was
during the pandemic yeah yeah sure was
wow
gross
this is harsh well you made it we did 63
16 months is you guys went hard after
this yeah what was the switch where you
guys went now we're not going to fool
around with this anymore
that was carolyn uh that was her family
remember she asked me and we got engaged
in december of 2019 and she asked me she
said hey i think that you know we should
take this class together and money was
just never something talked about when i
was a kid in my house we just you know
just never came up and i was kind of
like ah yeah okay maybe we'll see and
then i remember i was working on a car
with her dad and uh he kind of looked at
me and said so you're gonna be at that
class monday right i was like wow future
father-in-law says it to you you kind of
perk up like
[Applause]
so i was like yep absolutely we did it
and then uh i mean i was just awestruck
by the some of the things you said in
the first class wow um a lot of the
things that you said uh i heard thrown
around my house when i was a kid you
know like how much down how much a month
and i was really tuned in from there on
out and uh and we just went gazelle
intense ever since wow so carolyn it
sounds like you grew up a financial
peace baby a little bit a little bit mom
and dad were already into this stuff
yeah they took the class and then they
actually taught our class so oh cool
yeah oh you're going to be at the class
monday that i'm teaching yeah that made
it a little bit more interesting
yeah so i'm taking roll by the way i got
him back because uh
we went around the table and said why we
were there in our first class and um
my reason was my crazy father-in-law a
future father unless i should be here
nobody in the in the room knew it was
him except the three of us oh that's
correct a nice little moment i love that
that's great you might as well have some
fun with it absolutely that's awesome
but it didn't take long you were uh
you just had never been uh exposed to
these ideas and the first class you went
oh yeah
yeah yeah yeah absolutely at um
like you said like poor people ask how
much john how much month right if you
can't afford something you can't buy it
save up for it be patient be mature
and you'll get you'll get there so that
really resonated with me and uh yeah i
just i can't believe we're here doing
this it's pretty cool that's pretty cool
well i'm so excited for you what a great
way to go through your engagement oh and
to then enter in and finish and carolyn
finishes up helps him finish up getting
it paid off and
mom and dad are cheering you on along
the way way to go if you get married
during kovit nothing's stopping you guys
they've already been through the world
they didn't just get married they got
married went to the father-in-law's fbu
class and got out of debt that's like a
threesome go and do hard things go to
the father-in-law's fbi class probably a
little more difficult than getting
married during a pandemic
i love this story so this is great you
guys are a young couple how old are you
two we just turned 25. oh my goodness
this is inspiring so what do you tell
people the key to getting out of that is
well for me as the nerd i definitely
think the budget is the key um being
able to see where your money goes and
control where you can put some of your
money definitely was the key for me
yeah yeah from i mean i agree with her
there i never thought that i would live
on a budget in my life and now the first
thing i do when i come out of the store
is get my every dollar up out and uh but
from where i am you have to be okay
saying no to doing things right like my
buddies uh took a trip to vegas in may
and we were just so close that i was not
gonna put anything in the way of us
paying this off and uh we moved our debt
free data by like i think like 12 13
months um from when it was originally
when we first got married and we're
making those salaries so
um you have to be okay saying no to
things you can't have the fomo you have
to just trust what you're doing and if
people say that you're crazy look at
each other smile and say we're doing the
right thing that's that's good my granny
used to say crazy like a fox yeah yep
yep i like it so you have to do that you
have to work so if your broke friends
are making fun of your financial plan
you are right on track yeah absolutely
well done you guys i'm so proud of y'all
thank you
and i know mom and dad are and who were
your other cheerleaders other than the
obvious ones sitting to your right each
other we were especially carolyn i mean
she uh she would not take no for an
answer and and really uh worked with me
and was was very understanding that i
had not come up in a family like this
right uh you know i'm very proud of the
way that i was raised blue collar
hard-working but just the financial
stuff wasn't there and
she was very patient with me
i think when we look back at our budgets
from the beginning i think my free spend
was like 150 bucks and now it's like 30.
both of us are at 30 dollars and we're
cool there
it's just amazing like you get track of
your money and see how much money you
really waste uh you know she helped me
see that so she was definitely my
biggest cheerleader i'm very blessed wow
wow what a great way to start your
marriage this is amazing and look at
dave you're 25 and they say we're not
going to wait on student loan
forgiveness we're going to forgive it
ourselves by paying it off what a
concept
you guys are awesome i just love this
story and i know you're inspiring a lot
of other young couples out there who may
not be on the same page and you would
say go through financial peace
university that's what did it for you
guys yeah yeah i mean you have to build
that solid foundation right i mean we
are really trying to change the future
of of our last name it's not going to
mean swipe a card anymore it's going to
mean pay for cash plan for things
um and in doing that you have to build a
solid foundation together you have to be
on the same page so if you're not take
the class it is absolutely worth every
penny yeah
way to go guys thank you thanks for the
ad
but i'm so proud of you guys thank you
we got a copy of legacy journey for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure as you said you've changed your
legacy you've changed your family tree
changed your name what it means now a
whole new brand way to go very cool and
a copy total money makeover for you to
give away knock one of your uh buddies
right on the head with it and maybe you
can wake them up and get them going you
never know you never know that's how
most of us get inspired is through our
friends and our family and uh much more
so than some dude on a radio 1000 miles
away so um way to go you guys thank you
very well done all right alec and
carolyn
from pittsburgh pennsylvania
63 000 paid off in 16 months got married
in the pandemic and did it all the extra
side hustles and everything making 75 to
90 plus side hustles count it down let's
hear a debt-free scream
three
[Applause]
with the kiss to top it off that's it
the newlywed look i love it that's
fabulous good stuff congratulations you
guys
folks uh
big announcement coming up after this
break uh we put it out on social media a
little bit earlier today and out on some
of the media wires
and we will let you guys in on it and uh
just a few minutes after this break be
sure you stay tuned in
um
a brand new endeavor for the ramsey team
and uh really really really excited
about it uh and it's perfect on the
heels of their
debt-free scream from their student
loans newly married 25 years old and
they're free
the problem is not enough people in
america
are where they are
a lot of people are hurting
on this subject that's a good tease i'm
getting excited about it at first i was
like i don't know what this is and i
caught on nah i'm real sharp
i suspected you would
figure this out i'm real positive of all
people i would suspect that you would
figure this out it's perfect yeah i love
it all right this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
if you aren't strapped with student loan
payments odds are you know someone who
is millions are having to put off things
like buying a house having kids
because they're stuck
or even worse they're waiting and
waiting and waiting and waiting and
waiting for a government to save them
that's a joke
so we took our
unbelievably popular
podcast
borrowed future
and have produced a new full-length
world-class documentary called borrowed
future
it in cover uncovers the dark side of
the student loan industry and it exposes
how the system is built
to work against you
the date
save the date and make a point to watch
the release date for the documentary
will be on october 14th
and you'll see
all of us weigh in on the epic failure
otherwise known as the student loan
program featured interviews from
industry insiders and thought leaders
like seth godin uh seth fratman dr john
deloney uh we're coming at this hard
we're going to take big swings at the
student loan problem with the goal to
educate parents and students across this
country of the truth
you do not have to take out loans
to get a college education
it is important to graduate debt-free
and avoid the predatory student loan
industry and your predatory government
borrowed future premieres on digital
platforms everywhere
october 14th
mark your calendars go to
borrowedfuture.com
but uh we'll give you the when we get a
little bit closer we'll have all of the
distribution tied down but the major
digital platforms will all be carrying
it um
they've all made commitments to us and
we'll have to get it tied down before we
can actually announce exactly who and
when and where but october 14th they'll
all be lined up by then and we'll let
you know uh this thing's gonna be huge
george i can't wait i went to the
website last night i watched the trailer
i signed up for the mailing list i
marked my calendar i did all the things
because i was legitimately that excited
about it it's gonna be so good the team
did an incredible job it is world class
yeah the uh our ramsey networks
production team is um off the chain yeah
i mean they are very good
and uh i mean my wife and i are watching
the trailer in my living room uh i don't
know three or four weeks ago when they
got the trailer done we watched of
course screen the actual documentary as
well but we're watching the trailer
we're going wow
that's our company that did that wow
it's pretty cool yeah it's pretty cool
because it's gonna mess you up if you're
thinking about borrowing money to go to
college it's going to mess you up
if you don't
get in your
governmental
congressman and senator's face about
stopping this student loan program it's
a disaster you're going to stir up a
ruckus dave if you're not careful uh
it's it's a spiritual gift of mine
george thank you i'm good at stirring up
well if you've got student loans and
you're going to watch this and get even
angrier and go i got to pay this thing
off asap i don't want this in my life if
you sit around waiting on the government
to do it it's not the the process here
it's just once you get in the underbelly
of this and you see how what some of the
evil and manipulative uh uh
intent was from day one of this thing
and so who some of the players are and
how they acted it's unbelievable and
then you see people's lives are just on
the
you know they're just wrecked yeah he's
wrecked there's a lot of villains in the
story and i'd be shocked if anyone could
walk away from that documentary and go i
still think student loans are good debt
dave yeah wow they help a lot of people
there there'll be some idiot that will
but not as many it's pretty convincing
it really is borrowed future.com the uh
go ahead and mark your mark your
calendars it's going to be a big fall
comes out october the 14th debbie is
with us in detroit hi debbie welcome to
the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up
my husband and i made a huge mistake
we moved into a houseboat uh two months
ago
and with the housing market being so
crazy and lots of competition for homes
we made a mistake of buying a house for
more than we wanted to spend
um we paid over lift and appraisal
and
we're now in a house that um
we just feel like we can't afford the
mortgage payment
it also has
a pool
that is much more of an expense than we
thought it would be
the house
needs a lot of repairs and some things
have come up in the last couple of
months that we didn't realize we're
going to need to be repaired right away
so my question is
should we
plan on selling it
or
stay for at least two years
and then not have to worry about capital
gains
but if we sell it now
we would probably
walk away with you know losing about 40
grand
there is no capital gain when you lose
money
right but on the odd chance if we were
if you broke even if you break even
there's no capital gain
capital gain would only occur if you
made a profit
right
so it doesn't sound like that's a
problem
yeah
but if we sold it for what we bought it
if we just broke even we'd probably lose
about 40 grand
with closing costs and everything
so what's your house payment
um well that's the other thing too it's
more than what we thought it would be
with um the property taxes are going to
be
more than we had planned for so with
property taxes and insurance about 2
dollars alone and what's your
monthly take-home pay in your household
about nine thousand okay
all right
well you're slightly above what we would
tell you but not a huge amount
it doesn't sound like this
your house payment's not 40 of your
take-home pay
um
this sounds more emotional than
mathematical
okay
because we feel like we've been bleeding
money ever since we moved into the house
because of the pool and the repairs that
have been needed and what have you spent
on repairs
i'm sorry what have you spent on repairs
um
well with the pool it's been
uh
over a thousand dollars um with the
repair we just had a garage door
repaired that was over seven hundred
we need uh what did you pay for that
house huh
um
we paid 410 for it
and you had
fifteen hundred dollars worth of repairs
and you're panicking
yeah
well you make 100 you make 140 000 a
year
yeah well yeah yeah
this is emotional it doesn't sound like
you're bleeding out it feels like you
got a little scrape on the knee but it's
just a lot it sounds like it's more
stress of just we're having a i think
you were super impulsive and you did
something that you wished you hadn't
done and that's what's killing you the
math's not killing you okay
i mean we should it's not ideal
yeah but um
i i probably would just breathe a little
bit here um okay you know i i
okay here's the thing the house
payment's not out of control the repairs
are not 28 thousand dollars in one month
there were 1400 in one month
and you make 140. there's nothing here
that's causing red sirens to go off and
fireworks and panic
in the numbers okay now i understand you
have a deep sense of regret because you
feel like you impulsed and overpaid
but so i don't want to trade a fourteen
hundred dollar repair and a house
payment is slightly over the margins we
teach which are conservative for a forty
thousand dollar loss
right
well the other thing that i'm worried
about too is um we moved with our jobs
because now we can do our jobs from
anywhere after covid and there is a
chance that my salary could be decreased
based on
where we're living now well if that
happens and you can't afford the house
we can talk about selling it then but we
don't sell a house on what might happen
the house might get hit by a tornado too
yeah but we're not gonna sell it because
it might
debbie do you guys have any other debt
other than this mortgage um uh we do
have a car payment um we owe about 12
grand on a car we only have one car and
then we um just from the move we've got
about 6 000 on credit cards
so it sounds like there's some other
pieces to this puzzle that are causing
this stress do you have an emergency
fund
um we have about 25 000 in savings okay
i would write a check and pay off the
credit card and cut it up and pay off
the car today
right okay and you guys need to get on a
budget you are not in control with your
spending
that's where the stress is coming from
the sense of chaos is where the stress
is not the actual math there was more to
it i think she's bleeding out more from
these payments versus the mortgage and i
think once she gets that out of her life
they pay down the debt they refill the
emergency fund she's gonna breathe and
go okay no car payment no no credit card
and be on a written plan with every
dollar where you know you're under
control
both you and your husband looking at the
numbers every month stress level goes
down
then if you want to sell the house when
it's not a forty thousand dollar loss
four thousand dollar loss maybe
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsay advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we talk about your life
and your money open phones at triple
eight eight two five five
two two five audra is with us in
hastings nebraska to start off this hour
hey audra what's up
hi dave and george um i said the first
thank you for changing my life um
i'd prefer to call you for a better
circumstance um
but in april of 2020 i became debt free
from
a lot of divorce and student loan debt
and now i'm on baby set four through six
good but i'm also saving
yeah i'm also saving for a car in a
house
i'm 35 with two kids and my 20 year term
life policy
ends at 43
so i thought i would look into getting
another one before i turned 40 because i
thought i'd be a lot further along than
i am right now
long story short the urinalysis came
back showing potential kidney damage so
they had me repeat it twice
um those also came back showing the
damage so
um i have checked with my gp and he
referred me to a kidney position but
they gave the insurance company gave me
a table b category um
for 500 000
for 30 years
at 113 a month which
i think is extremely high um i currently
pay 18 a month for my 500 000 policy
that i got when i was 20 in my 20s
thanks to you
and i have 13 days left to decide if i
want to get this rate or i can wait two
years and gamble if my test is going to
be better
he said i could go back to the preferred
rate or if it's worse i'm uninsurable
what is the nature of your kidney damage
do you have any idea what caused it
i i don't even know that that it's
actual damage yet i just know that the
test
i got that part but i mean you don't you
don't there wasn't an event that you can
look back and go oh that's where the
kidney damage came from
oh um
[Music]
not to my knowledge um okay i did a test
otherwise you're 35 and healthy
yeah and your household and your income
is what
oh very small um under 15 a year
why
i work from home and i raise my two
girls and
their dad
he's with us we're together
um but i work from home and so i'm there
full-time daycare and so i do web design
and graphic design from home
so i would say i work part-time
while also i'm a little bit confused i
thought you said you were divorced now
you said their dad is there
oh i'm their dad is not um my ex-husband
that was that was an abusive marriage
that i got out of and then i met their
dad
how old are your children
four
and
14 months
okay all right
and their dad makes how much money
um
28 30 000
so neither one of you are doing very
well in your careers
no
financially though
you know i'm debt free he has some
student loan debt
um
yeah but you're starving but you're
starving to death
well you don't have any money
so no you don't need this life insurance
is the answer to your question
it's too expensive it's ridiculous in
your situation
okay
now what was life insurance for we got
500 000 there it's good for eight more
years hopefully during that eight years
your health will uh not deteriorate will
instead get better if you take good care
of yourself also during that eight years
if you want to make sure your children
are taken care of it would involve
marrying their dad
and it would involve you guys as a
married couple having a financial plan
that takes care of your careers and both
of you start working on your careers
because both of you need to double your
income in the next three years
okay
because really what what your your kids
are vulnerable because of your marital
status status and because of
your your low incomes more than your
insurance issue
and so that's what i would tell you to
do if i was your dad
and i've got one that's your age by the
way
so yeah audra i think if you can get a
job doing graphic design you might make
enough money to actually pay for some
child care for them and like dave's
saying the goal of this life insurance
is to replace your income in case
something happens right now that's 15k
there's not a lot going on there so
number one i would check i don't know
where you shopped your rates with but
maybe check with our friends at xander
see what that would be like going
forward if you want to check that later
on but i don't think you need 30 years
because if you follow our plan you're
going to be doing really well 30 years
from now to where you're self-insured
that's what we talk about well and we
tell you 15 to 20 your level term with
zander insurance let them shop when you
need insurance but you've got you've got
life insurance more than you need today
it's very inexpensive and it has eight
years left on it so sometime in the next
eight years you need to address this
subject but during that time
stabilizing your household uh from a
career perspective and a marital status
standpoint will be the best thing for
your kids financially for survivability
or sustainability if something happened
to you yeah and that's what the life
insurance is all about what are we
trying to do there we're trying to make
sure the kids are okay
and so the advice i'm giving you is
exact same thing we're trying to make
sure the kids are okay we got bigger
fish to fry than the term life right now
we've got to get this career situation
we got to get the income up and put
ourselves in a good financial position
yeah and um and uh
you know i i think i think there's still
some
hesitation on your part based on the way
you told the story and your language
both
um
about marriage because you were in a bad
one
and um
uh that was abusive and i i appreciate
that i know that that was a horrible
thing and a
certain amount of ptsd goes with that
kind of garbage that kind of trauma i
don't disagree with that but i'm not
looking at your life through the lens of
the past i'm looking at your life
through the lens of the future
and where are you going what's the
vision for you in the next
25 years
where you're going to be in the next
eight years
uh you could be in such a great position
in eight years that the four-year-old is
12.
uh the baby is um 10
and
you know you're going to be in such a
good position financially that the life
insurance is not going to be an issue
that could happen in eight years but
you're going to have to have make some
pretty serious moves to get you in that
direction
so good question and we appreciate you
calling in and being part of the show
today
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five
two two five george campbell ramsey
personality is my co-host today he is
the host of a brand new podcast that we
launched two weeks ago called the fine
print it came out as number one in the
business section
and uh the third episode dropped
yesterday on monday the third of ten so
be sure and check out the fine print
remember when your dad said read the
fine print well it's because you get
messed over if you don't george does the
digging to tell you what's going on in
the fine print
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what makes our show unique is that we
genuinely care about our listeners we're
intentional about choosing the best
advertisers to recommend blinds.com is
no exception they offer high quality
window treatments at unbelievable prices
and they make it simple to shop blinds
shades and interior shutters with easy
online ordering free shipping and a
guaranteed perfect fit go to blinds.com
and take advantage of this week's
special savings
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five
five two two five lucas is in phoenix
hey lucas what's up
nothing much dave how are you doing
better than i deserve how can i help
so i am 19 years old i just graduated
high school probably about two months
ago i have no debt
um i've been working a life guarding job
here in arizona for about roughly four
years so i'm on good terms with them
however it doesn't pay a lot so i've
been incorporating my new landscaping
business um and then that's been really
taken off um so
the issue is with all of this is i've
been recently kicked out of the home and
it's not been for you know not going to
college or being lazy or alcohol or
drugs or anything like that um it's just
really you don't really see eye to eye
and we saw we tried going to like you
know therapy and whatnot to try to work
through that but this really hasn't been
working out so my mom wanted me out and
i've been staying with a friend of mine
who goes to my same church and so we've
been you know he's been mentoring me and
kind of teaching me some stuff about
finances and whatnot just trying to help
me get my feet up underneath me i mean
so my whole goal here is to try to do a
minimal a minimalistic mindset um just
so that way i can focus into more of my
future not my you know like the present
and you know wasting money on certain
things and so right now i have no credit
history um and so it's very difficult to
you know buy anything that's going to
help me live somewhere right so um
currently i'm with him and so i'm
thinking of
getting like a mini camper that i can
pull on the back of my truck and i have
an actual place to park it
and it's about 17 000 um outright so if
i walk out the door it's about 17 000 to
buy that i don't want to lease it very
you know because
they go down in value so quickly and
it's really just a bad deal that way so
i really don't know what to do because
all i have right now is about thirty
seven to four thousand dollars
that's kind of a scary place lucas
yeah yeah it's it really uh it is and um
yeah it kind of
woke me up a little bit yeah
so um
you have a landscaping business
and you are making what kind of income
so um when i'm just kind of using it as
a side gig which was um you know a
couple years ago it was making in you
know 100 bucks here 300 there number
what do you mean what do you make you
need money right now what are you making
right now correct
right now um like for the past week or
so i've probably brought in about
two thousand dollars
within a week and a half two weeks doing
what
uh just landscaping
okay all right and so you're out there
hustling up landscaping business right
oh yeah i'm out there every single day
um and then
my land might you know my lifeguarding
that um if i was to work close to 40
hours a week i'm making about 1407 after
taxes every two weeks the paycheck
that's bringing me down about 813 to 800
bucks which is nothing so
yeah the landscaping is going to make
you a lot more
um if you can get that business
on top of that what
well i'm just i'm working for myself so
it's more meaningful it has greater
potential yeah that type of stuff right
this second i don't give a crap about
that i'm just trying to get you where
you have shelter and food
yeah
your life's meaning is way down my list
right now for you i just want you to
have a place to live and food
and
stability sustainability then we can
worry about meaning and
self-actualization and
um those kinds of things but right now
i've got a 19 year old homeless kid
um
on the phone and that that's what's
running through my head so
um
no you do not need to buy a 17 000
camper under any circumstances
okay okay not a good move you have four
thousand dollars if you can find a ratio
used one for a thousand bucks which you
probably actually can
and you want to live in that for
uh four months
while you
build up some more cash and stabilize
your income and then go rent an
apartment with a roommate
that's okay
if you can can you can you live
she said i mean as long as it it takes
as long as i'm working my you know
pardon me working on my butt off to get
myself stabilized and i do have a very
good work ethic like i'm out here
working a ton i'm not i'm not
questioning that okay so right um
so we need to define that because when
someone comes to stay in my home i want
to know when they're leaving
yes and i don't want to stay there
because i know i know but i just as long
as it takes could be until you're 29 he
didn't mean that so i want to know what
he meant
so what he's meaning is like six months
okay you know max let's just do that
listen you know let's just do that let's
just stay there for a while
okay and and so listen listen and build
up how big a pile of cash
can you build up
during that time and get your income
stabilized and then get a roommate right
yeah i mean it sounds like you have very
little expenses right now lucas so i
want you to take advantage of that while
this this man has given you a lot of
grace uh and like dave saying i would
not go into debt for this camper i know
you want to live this minimalist life
and i respect that that's not minimalist
but 17 000 camper when you're broke is
not minimalist yeah
you i think you should need to rent and
get a roommate if that after that six
months you don't have enough for that
camper but
that camper is not going up in value and
it's a depreciating asset so it's
basically like you saying hey can i take
out a loan for 17 000 to get a truck and
we're going to say no so
i want you to to live your dreams you're
19. you've got a lot of life ahead of
you but right now you need a solid
foundation you don't have that and so
you've got a great work ethic like
you're talking about use that to your
advantage and use this free rent to your
advantage and sock away maybe you could
save up five ten grand go rent somewhere
for another six months and maybe a year
or two from now you get that camper
here's my prediction okay
listen just listening to you if you'll
stay on the track and probably gonna
lose the lifeguard job for more hours on
the landscaping if you can get more and
more and more landscaping business
you're gonna stabilize your income in
the next four months at three to four
thousand dollars a month
and you're gonna have about ten thousand
dollars in the bank four months from now
with that situation you can go rent an
apartment
and get a roommate or rent a room from
somebody
uh very inexpensively and then take your
next step
which is continue to continue to grow
your business and start thinking about
your careers but paying cash all the way
this camper
it sounds kind of romantic and like
you're again you're being sacrificial or
something but it's really going to end
up being a long-term bad play
and uh so i'm going to talk you out of
that one yeah it's a tough lifestyle i
know it sounds fun i mean you're 19. you
could probably swing it for a year or
two but eventually you just want a real
place to go and sleep so
yeah and just you know here's the thing
if you can get your home situation
sustainable and stabilized then you can
start working on your career and you can
start looking out and thinking about
your future and you can start thinking
about you know investing and upgrading
and
whatever you know taking some classes or
doing whatever it is you want to do with
your life there's a lot of things you
can do from there but for right now
let's get
the food shelter clothing transportation
and utilities going and get those basic
things underway and that's what i'd tell
you to do first
and um along the way
um
even if you're not living there
stay in touch with your mom
your dad
tell them what's going on
um not i don't know what all has
happened here i can't tell
um but that's not what this call is
about but it is what it's about that's
what puts you here
um so i i want you to continue to work
on that relationship if there's any way
possible
obviously if you can't you can't but um
you you want to have tried everything
you do not want to live in regret on
that
and so
um
you know maybe you and your mom can be
friends when you don't live there maybe
that takes the stress off of it i don't
know how that works in your world
but um
just make sure you just let them know
you're okay and that you're working
and um
that you care about them and so on just
continue to that connection i think
that'll be very valuable for you
ten years from now especially um maybe
not ten minutes from now but ten years
from now
wow yeah i mean he just got punched in
the face a little bit and he's 19. he's
having to grow up fast but i think if he
can build his foundation for a little
while and get back on his feet he's
gonna be just fine
you tell he's a good kid good work ethic
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage clayton and gazella are
with us hey guys how are you we're great
how are you excited welcome good to have
you where do you live uh fort myers
florida awesome how much did you pay off
uh we paid just under 70 000 in 18
months all right
very good and your range of income
during that year and a half uh we
started right around 110 and we ended at
that time right around 190. whoa
nice jump what do y'all do for a living
i am a project manager at a non-profit
and i do sales for a payroll and hr tech
company ah okay all right so uh you
change jobs or just get big raises or
just worked a ton of overtime what
happened to your income going up you're
almost double that's a great question
yeah so um we changed jobs and actually
my job it was not a choice i was
actually one of the millions of people
that got laid off because of covid oh
yeah um but you know i kind of took that
as an opportunity to kind of like look
at myself and like what do i really want
to do and really try to better myself
and along that same time a better
opportunity presented itself for clayton
yep so um yeah my my job well i was
lucky enough not to get laid off i was
really affected by the pandemic in the
sense that i worked in um
conferences and events so obviously
there were none um so i was in a sales
role there as well i kind of had another
opportunity just
due to um you know a friend that just
kind of fell in my lap and it couldn't
have worked out any better for us so
we're one of the few lucky ones that
came out on the other side much better
off than we were before so we're very
blessed in that i think it had something
to do with more than just luck that's
definitely yeah that has to do with
you're taking action absolutely instead
of being uh taking a victim pose yes
absolutely well done you guys thank you
very well what kind of debt was the 70
000 that's another great question we're
pretty normal um
it ranged from student loans credit
cards two cars
medical bills am i forgetting anything
to do the personal ones and a personal
loan yeah quite the range
you're normal yeah everything how long
y'all been married uh we just got
married in january oh wow yeah okay
all right so you started this process
obviously before marriage as individuals
yes we did and then worked your way on
through it what got you started on this
you go ahead um so
i had heard about you especially through
my older brother but at that point i was
like dave ramsey who i don't need him um
and then clay and when him and i first
started dating he started doing it and
he never like came to me about it but i
kind of saw he was doing it and i was
like you know this is the person i want
to marry and he's really preparing
himself i need to do the same because i
want to bring into this marriage and so
we can go into this marriage together
wow um
so that's really what inspired me and at
that point i moved out of my parents
house moved into a little studio by
myself and when i saw how much i was
paying in rent i'm like if i would have
saved this every single month like i
would be set but instead i was just
spending no budget i put together a
budget and that's when i really realized
wow this money is just kind of going
everywhere yeah
yeah and same here um you know i was
making great money before and
i guess i came to
when i read your book for the first time
i think that i came to the end of it and
realized i'm making all this money i
don't have any of it you know
so
um and then yeah just moving moving
forward we we got engaged and we were
moving toward getting married we were
working the plan separate and um for us
at that time i think our big motivation
was just we're gonna pour the foundation
for a family right um that was that was
the biggest motivation we you know we
had our um
our board up in our house where we had
our uh our debt countdown going on um
after we got married and a big picture
of the house we wanted to build after we
finished and yeah
um
that was that was our why very cool yeah
and that drove you then well done well
done so it's amazing when you tell these
dollars what to do that they will behave
it is pretty amazing yeah they otherwise
are pretty unruly oh yeah i mean you had
a moment where you just went i got to
make some changes here because i have
future goals and you stopped living in
the present both of you and you said
what are our future goals together and
that to me is one of the most powerful
elements when you get a couple that
comes together go we're going to pay
this thing off and we're going to do it
in 18 months
yeah it's incredible pretty cool what
advice do you have to somebody if they
want to get out of debt what do they
need to do i think the biggest i mean
the biggest thing was the budget for
sure sticking to the budget was super
hard and we definitely had a few
setbacks where we you know could have
done better along the way but we didn't
let it stop us we just kept moving
forward and you know look to the next
month and
um having to say no a lot was definitely
difficult that was super super tough for
me just i was more of a homebody so
maybe not as difficult for her but you
know i like to go out and hang out with
people and stuff you know be out and
having a good time and it was it was
difficult at first but um yeah and then
just not don't forget your why um
because i know it was difficult for me
like especially with an age of social
media where you see this person getting
a new car or getting new shoes getting a
new purse just sharing it all and i'm
like i want that but i can't have it
because i need to remember why i'm doing
this and i would sit there at the table
and it's hard to post self-discipline on
social media there's not much to post
[Laughter]
and you know sometimes i'd be there at
the dinner table when i start crying
because i'm like i want all of these
things but i'm like i know that i can't
have them right now and i would sit
there and i'm like you need to live like
no one else so you can live and you can
give like no one else and like and to
just be able to have a partner who so
that is in it with you together is just
a blessing
and i think that that's really why we've
been so successful is because we feed
off of each other and we celebrate every
single little one we're always on the
same page yeah yeah and you did it in 18
months we did it
and we cashflowed a wedding yeah we
cashfield
that's in there too yeah wow wow you
guys are rock stars very very well done
well we're very proud of you guys
excellent excellent job other than the
two of you who are your biggest
cheerleaders
i think my brother and his wife colin
and jenny um they worked the plan before
we did and seeing them was super
inspiring and like she mentioned her
brother fabian and
sister-in-law vanessa they were working
the plan as well and they they paid off
all their all their debt they're working
out towards paying off their house so um
wow i meant it's funny she's going to
kill me for mentioning it but vanessa
wanted to build the pool
and uh i said at dinner one night you
know is dave ramsey going to be happy
about you building the pool instead of
paying off the house
and uh three weeks later three weeks
later he uh he she texted giselle and
said you can thank clayton we're paying
off the house now
yeah and i think that's been the
funniest part is we've talked to other
couples who have done it and typically
the wife was not on board at first and
they're like is that how you felt and
i'm like no actually i did it myself i'm
like i tell him like i call myself a
little dave ramsett
and i think sometimes which is really
nice because you know like i said we
really encourage each other um but it's
just like remembering your why and i'm
like this is we're really building our
foundation and taking it one step at a
time and just learning to be patient
yeah that's very cool well
congratulations you guys thank you so
much very proud of you we got a copy of
the legacy journey for you that is the
next chapter in your story for sure as
you continue to change your whole family
tree in your lives you've just got a
great start going
very very well done and a copy total
money makeover for you to give away to
somebody as you've been yacking about
this while you're doing it somebody
needs a copy of that book yeah and uh
you go oh i make too much money to be
this bro there you go that's a great
line very good stuff very cool all right
clayton and gazella fort myers florida
seventy thousand dollars paid off in 18
months making 110 to 190 count it down
let's hear a debt free screen
three three two one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is how it's done can't help but
smile watching that happen that's fun
well they they're incredible young
couple they got a great start they make
a lot of money oh yeah and they have
paid off everything very very quickly
they get to can
be done the number of times
that someone does their debt free stream
on this show that their income went down
during the process of this is almost
zero
very close to a hundred percent of the
time the income during the time they're
working on getting out of debt goes up
what do you attribute that to
i think they needed more money to get
out of debt and they're willing to do
whatever you start looking around going
where can i get more money yeah you know
and that's part of it and then part of
it is i i think that um
you know god is looking he says you know
when you're faithful with the little
things i'll give you more to manage
and so he goes oh look at that one that
one's trust worthy
worthy of trust
they now are demonstrating so that we
can give them a little more that's
powerful and i i i think that's part of
it i think it's blessings of the lord
yeah but uh but part of it is just
simply you look around you go i need
some more money and you go i need a
different job this one sucks yeah or i
need a great side hustle because there's
a great place to go when you're broke to
work and
that you know
because i want to get out that faster so
i can move on with my life and that's
the thing it's just for right now you
heard her say that it's not forever 18
months
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no parent ever wants their child to
experience the panic of being unprepared
for an emergency
but teaching your kids how to be smart
with money is a really big job well
we've got your back we'll help you
our digital self-study courses
they help you rest assured that your
teen will know
the right way to handle money no matter
what curveballs life might throw down
the road i mean wouldn't you have liked
to heard all this stuff when you were
like a teen
yeah well you can the best part no
instructor is needed your teen has a
tablet or a computer they're all set all
you do is text
study to 33 789 and you can learn more
about the different courses we have
available for your middle or high
schooler text self study 233789
our question today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings free samples free
shipping and new promos all the time you
save money always use the promo code
ramseyblinds.com a great american
company today's question comes from
sharon in iowa my husband and i lost our
jobs last year when the pandemic hit
we're both receiving unemployment
benefits and while we'd like to find
work being able to stay home means we
don't have to pay for child care is it
okay for us to stay home with our kids
or should we be looking for jobs
well looks like we need some more
information here
but
i mean i like the idea of them staying
home if they're able to financially
i don't like them living off the
unemployment benefits though that's how
they're staying home
i think they need to get back to work
yeah
so let me tell you what really benefits
your children
showing them how to live your life
properly
not working
is not a model that you want your
children to follow
living letting the government take care
of you
when you have the ability to go and work
is not a model that will bring your
children
a good full fruitful dignity-filled life
work brings dignity
living off the dole of the state does
not
and uh you're teaching your children a
horrible lesson you're modeling them a
horrible lesson and calling it under the
name of nurturing
and so no i i don't think you're doing
right i think you need to get to work
now i don't know if both of you need to
go to work i don't know what your
financial status is
but um
that's completely up to you as to
whether uh one spouse or the other is
able to stay home while the other works
but you know teaching your children that
they that the best thing to do is live
off the do the least possible amount you
can do and let the government pay for
your life is not a lesson that's
valuable for your children's future
bad parent bad parent
not nurturing parent
um bad call no no don't do that i could
be wrong but not i think i think i mean
both of them are on these i really
couldn't be wrong there's no possible
way i'm wrong on this not yet 30 years
you haven't been wrong once
wrong record but this one i'm not wrong
okay
actually i'm
being very nice on this one compared to
what i you're being kind of you can't
you can't talk to him so you're being a
little kinder yes that's right talking
into the wind that's it it's um that's
that's yeah that's one thing you could
be doing yeah
adam is in boston hey adam how are you
i'm doing all right thanks so much for
taking my call i really appreciate it
sure how can we help so uh
my uh my beloved dad passed away a
couple weeks ago um he
was my hero and uh we're all taking it
pretty hard but you know he worked his
entire life to make sure we were all
looked after
and um my mother is to be receiving uh
quite a bit of life insurance money and
she's asked me to kind of help her
figure out how to sort out what to do
with all of it and i was going to call
and uh get some advice from the smartest
folks i know wow i'm sorry
me too uh he was my hero how how old was
he
uh he was 74.
been fighting prostate cancer for about
a decade and
it finally won wow
i'm so sorry and so you are thank you
you are 35.
uh roughly yeah 37. you got it pretty
close
and uh and you kind of look after my mom
she's had some tough years as well as
he's been really sick and has some of
her own medical issues and so i'm
stepping in to just sort of help guide
her right now um on the financial side
and many other ways and
so she's you know set to receive
my dad if i said he really tried to
prepare
for this moment she said to receive
about 1.8 million dollars in life
insurance
the uh she currently doesn't have any
debt other than a
there's a heloc on the house on the
primary home which was for about uh
three hundred thousand dollars and then
a hundred and fifty thousand dollar
mortgage on a vacation home the primary
home's worth about a million dollars the
vacation home is worth uh about seven
hundred thousand dollars and then she
also has about eight hundred thousand
dollars in traditional iras uh between
the two of them um and so i wanna tell
her that what you should probably do
next here is just pay off the mortgage
in the heloc uh and if you agree with
that i'm also curious um you know what
she should do
with the rest of it to make sure that uh
she's able to be okay for the next you
know decade or so she does not currently
work um she does get have a pension um
that's uh with his benefit from social
security will probably end up being
about twenty five hundred dollars a
month
okay
well she's got um
over three million dollars with a paid
for house and a paid for lake house and
so yes she's okay she's okay
you know there's no question financially
that um
i mean if it's invested just round
numbers what a 10 that's 300 000 a year
and they didn't spend anywhere near that
right okay so um thing number rule
number one um
when you lose someone
um
it's it's good to give yourself a little
space before making major decisions
because uh not only is her brain not
working great right now because of grief
neither is yours
i appreciate your calling and i'm not
trying to be insulting but if um if
something happened to my wife sharon i'm
the money guy and my first rule is i'm
not going to make any major decisions
right then
because
because my brain is in the fog of grief
because of my love for her and your love
for your dad is the same way okay
yep so let's just go slow there is
nothing to be
proven on how sophisticated you are
financially
so number one yeah go ahead and pay off
those two deaths that's kind of a
no-brainer and if you put the rest of it
in cds for six months and cry
and then decide how you want to invest
it that's not a bad plan at all
i think that's a big part of the advice
i needed to hear i the only reason it's
even on my mind is because all these
policies are been put in front of me and
i'm trying to figure out how to put the
claims in and otherwise i would love to
not think about this for a while yeah
get the claims in get the cash in the
bank
and um
you know and in three months
meet with a smart investor pro with your
mom
and start thinking about how we can
invest some of it
and three months later
actually make some of the investments
great you're not going to make any money
on this money but for six months whoopty
dupty
what's your mom need to live for six
months money-wise
i mean hardly anything she's
unfortunately 50 grand out too much in
these days
probably yeah yeah but put 50 grand in
her checking account
look at it with her put it online so you
can watch the balance so she doesn't get
into grief spending or something
and pay off these two loans and park the
rest of it in cds or a money market and
you can call a smart buster pro and park
it with them in a money market if you
want but you don't need to do anything
fancy just wait a little bit
and then
and then just cry for a while
it's amazing it's like everyone sort of
immediately comes at you with all the
things you need to do
and that's all i've wanted to do is
that's all i've been doing for three
weeks and i
you know it feels too soon to even be
wrestling with this stuff but it was
dropped in front of me and so i said
you're here you're a man of duty and
you're honoring your dad's memory by
taking care of your mom and that's a
wonderful thing but you guys do not have
to become sophisticated financial
investors in the next 24 hours in the
middle of this grief don't do it
go slow
take your time
you got plenty of money she's okay
there's no possible way you're going to
completely mess this up unless you guys
go play the lottery with this money or
go to vegas or something
you know
don't invest in beanie in beanie babies
or bitcoin just put it
put it in the bank and give yourself
some room
that's all you got to do
that puts this hour in the ramsey show
in the books
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com
and register we would love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
i'm dave ramsey your host george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
dan is with us in ventura california hi
dan how are you
hi dave hi george i'm i'm doing uh
pretty good um i was in your studio
audience last thursday and it was just
wonderful
thank you seeing you all in person it
was so reassuring and just it just made
me uh just lock down on the baby steps
cool when i got home i was back home in
ventura i i'm i'm a little confused
right now because i thought i was in
baby step six
um and uh my question is uh what
revolves around spousal support so
um
i'm wondering where spousal support fits
in the baby steps um i just finished my
divorce
about three months ago and my world has
been quite rocked
the last year or so i'm sorry
yeah so alimony would that not just be a
budget item george yeah is this just
ongoing support what's the details of
this
yeah yeah the basic the details are i'm
obligated to pay two thousand dollars a
month until february next year i mean
i've already already paid off the
attorneys and
uh lumps on payments and you know that
all the bad part of the divorce is is
over um except for the spousal support
so i'm paying you know i'm i'm 58 years
old on my home i make about a hundred
and two thousand dollars a year
um and i've been just cash flowing it
and but i do have the emergency fund of
about fifteen thousand i could use just
just to pay it off a hundred percent
so is this a one you could lump sum this
spousal support if you wanted to
well now that's a good question and the
marital separation agreement says i'm
supposed to pay her a few thousand
dollars a month until for 11 months
yeah which ends in february yeah
okay and you can just do that out of
your budget can't you
i i have been and i can yeah i would
just call as far as it's not really a
baby step item it's a budget item
i'll budget that okay yeah you have a 2
000 expense in your budget that's going
to go away in february
right it doesn't affect your baby steps
that's what i think i don't know what do
you think i'll show you a different one
consider it as debt i wouldn't say oh
you're in baby step two now you've got
to pay this thing off it's just a budget
line item and once it's done you're
gonna give yourself a raise and you can
continue on in the baby steps after that
but you said you have no debt except the
house right
that's correct you know no debt except
for the house and i hope to be on your
debt-free stage in about four years
that's great do you have margin left
over after the spousal support to put
extra on the mortgage
no
i have a part-time gig i'm also an
electrician on the side so i'm able to
make you know um maybe a thousand
dollars extra a month
um but it's tight right now very tight
in fact i'm i'm
i'm trying to make some behavioral
changes uh so are you you owe her twelve
thousand dollars uh six months of two
thousand bucks right
yes sir how contentious
is the relationship
uh
i think that answers it
it's not good
okay because here's why i ask okay you
could just do the two thousand dollars a
month for for six months that's fine and
you're done if it was if you called me
up and you said i have five years of
back alimony
i would call that a debt
and that's a lump sum that you got to
catch up but this is a monthly
obligation that you are current on
and it's not a debt it's just a payout
now if uh it depending on how
contentious here's an idea to throw into
the soup might not be worth anything but
you might have your attorney ask her
attorney if he pays this off in a lump
sum would there be a discount more than
willing to pay it monthly but if you
want all the money right now would you
take less than twelve thousand and i'd
use my emergency fund and clear it up if
you got a deal
okay plus gets rid of heart i did
yeah yeah exactly that's what i was
thinking to kind of get it out of my
life we're no longer using attorneys
we're communicating through email i
asked that question about two months ago
she says absolutely not you have to you
know abide by the agreement sure then
i'll do it that was my answer right here
sure yeah happy too just leave it alone
then forget it
okay my idea you've already tried my
idea forget it yeah
because sometimes people need money
or they want the lump sum enough to give
it a discount if they're not going to
give it a discount we'll just sit on the
money and pay it out monthly
which it sounds like she prefers anyway
so it's all right it's all good that's
fine
i i think so yeah so
that's the route i would go yeah and
once you're once you hit february then
you've got two thousand dollars back in
your life to pay down that mortgage and
it sounds like you're you want to be
intense about it and get rid of that
thing so i think you're in a good
situation like dave's saying i think you
just make these monthly payments out of
your budget and be done with it in six
months
brad's in memphis hey brad how can we
help
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
well i have a what would uncle dave say
a question we've been struggling through
this for a little while
uh we recently did our debt free stream
in april after paying off
in
196.20
months
and we're now in baby steps four five
and six
my wife and i have been moving towards
selling our house
ever since we finished baby step three
we have made a lot of bad choices in the
past with our money and now that we've
changed our behavior got out of debt
actually have money
we don't want to mess up good
if we sell our home our realtor told us
we'd net more than 100 grand after she
ran some comps
and we bought the house just three years
ago with a va loan and zero down this is
before we got smart
found money though
yes um
so
we make 160.
the mortgage is currently at 310
and
a new piece of information we recently
got was
we both have government jobs and have
been given eight weeks to get the covert
shot
neither of us are willing to do that
um
we've been able to use a religious
exemption in the past for things like
the flu but they have no idea if they're
going to allow that for this covet shot
that being said we do want to sell our
house with the equity
buy a piece of land and live in our paid
for rv while we save up uh
for building a home in cash
um we both received va disability
equaling about 30 000 a year
and so if we both lost our jobs
we would
barely be able to rob it we're debt free
with a piece of land and rv we could
survive without the jobs until we could
find something to replace it
um
how many kids
two kids sir what age
uh
15 and sorry a little nervous 13
and 15. okay that's right and um
uh
all of it sounds good but the rv part to
me
it sounds like hell to me
i live in an rv with two teenagers um
i see where you're painting and i see
where you're going i'd probably be
looking at maybe a used trailer
uh like a five thousand dollar one
because that way i'm not losing much
money when i get rid of it and then
start looking towards building very very
quickly as you land in your new careers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children and we had also just started a
real estate company and needed to find
health care coverage that would meet our
needs we were attracted to chm because
of its low monthly costs and the ability
to negotiate medical costs down
established in 1981 and accredited by
the better business bureau chm is here
to meet the needs of your growing family
or small business check us out at
chministries.org backslash budget we
absolutely believe in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
george campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones a triple eight
eight two five five
two two five if there's one thing that
2020 taught us about investing it's this
you cannot invest alone you absolutely
need someone in your life who knows the
market better than you and helps you
make smart decisions i love
do-it-yourselfers but diy investors
well the data tells us that we mess up
when we diy on investing especially when
there's a global crisis you invest in
the wrong things you get caught up in
trends you make rookie mistakes you can
build a portfolio based on what you read
in reddit
god don't do anything based on what
you're doing reddit
trust me uh you need don't need to add
any unnecessary stress in your life you
need to get some people in your corner
that can help you let 2020 be your
wake-up call never again
let your investments be at the mercy of
the emotions of a global crisis
go to ramseysolutions.com
smart vester
get in touch with one of our smart
vester pros and they'll sit down with
you and walk you through this sam's with
us in oahu hawaii hi sam how are you
hello hi sam
uh i'm sorry you have the wrong number
okay that works for me
uh
i did have the wrong number you're right
and that's sam in honolulu or
hawaii i pushed the wrong button hey sam
how are you
hey dave hey dave how are you doing
today good you sound a lot better now
how can i help
okay uh so
uh i'm in baby step number two i have my
thousand dollar emergency fund
uh my car my car was my first bet to pay
off on a debt snowball i had like 800
left on that so i paid that off um early
and um i also have other loans so i have
a two thousand dollar loan i have a uh
eight thousand dollar loan
uh nine thousand dollar loan and an
eleven thousand dollar loan
um
the eleven thousand dollar loan that i
have it's the same bank that uh i took
my car loan out from
and since i paid off my car early i
wanted to get my title from the bank
and because i have a
defaulted loan
uh with the same bank uh there they
won't release my title they're saying
it's cross-collateral
for that loan yep uh and uh the debt
recovery department for that bank
contacted me
and they're
i guess they wanted a lump sum
for the loan
and i don't have that money right now so
they're uh what did they offer you what
did they offer you on the loan
uh he didn't offer a lower amount he
just said if i could get the uh if i
could pay the 11 grand i asked him if i
could maybe make payments on it
um but he said now uh we would have to
go to court and um he's threatening to
sue me for the 11 grand
so i have no idea what to do i'm not
sure if how long has it been done you
paid so how long has it been since you
paid three years it's been three years
since i paid that loan
what's your car so uh i
my car is worth 7 500. the thing is i'm
a full-time uber driver so i need my car
i wasn't saying that
i'm just trying to figure out what's
going on all right so um okay so
uh what are you making what kind of
what's your income
i make about 4 000 a month
that's good
okay yes
all right um so the 11 000 was later on
in the debt snowball that's why i wasn't
planning on paying it now i was going to
take care of the next loan that was in
line yeah after my car what you've run
into here is what's called a dragnet
clause
standard
uh loan documents with the typical
commercial bank
allows them if you have a loan and it's
in default to cross-collateralize and
hold your collateral
i ran into that with commercial paper it
wasn't a car loan deal but it was
something else when i was going broke i
thought i had cleared this property and
i thought i was going to be able to move
it and take care of something else and i
go in the bank's like oh no we're going
to keep that deed thank you very much
and i ran into the exact same thing and
it's pretty much an emotional gut punch
because you think you're making progress
and then they take you out so what's the
name of this yeah what's the name of
this bank
uh it's the hawaii state federal credit
union okay which is the name you need to
remember the rest of your life that
keeps you so pissed off you never borrow
money again because you now know what it
feels like to be
yeah mine was called sun trust
okay so just to give you an idea but
anyway the um
you just remember for 30 years you're
still pissed off you know i mean i'm
never borrowing money again because the
way these
people
treat you
um so
uh
you need to scrape up some money really
fast and make them a lump sum offer like
five grand for this 11 and see if you
can discount and pay it off
okay stop everything in pile up cash and
make them a lump sum offer
okay would it be wise to um
possibly take out
a loan for the 12 grand and pay them
that and pay be wise to take out a loan
for seven grand and settle this settle
the 11.
okay because you already have an eleven
thousand dollar loan if at the end of
this conversation you have a seven
thousand dollar loan we made progress
okay i'm not telling you to borrow money
i'm telling you to move some of your
debt and make it more efficient
yeah so you haven't paid on the thing in
three years
the car is not worth seven on a repo lot
it's not worth three they don't want
your car it's an emotional play they've
got on you
okay they don't really want a three
thousand dollar car because that's what
it'll bring on repo lot if it's a seven
thousand dollar car it's not gonna bring
anything
so
they're not they're not gonna come out
of this in a good shape so call them a
call if you can get a loan get that
lined up and offer them five and settle
at seven and get it in writing that
that's a settlement in full
uh-huh
and um what if i do that and they're not
willing to take the seven they will
you're just gonna have to mess with them
a while
you just got to be hardcore
because it's been three years
where have they been they weren't all
happy and excited to go to a lawsuit
two years ago
why not
you know
it's just because you activated it when
you called one your title and they went
oh we got this guy
we got this guy by the nap we're going
to shake him a little bit
and that's what he feels like happening
oh it's exactly what happened
the borrower slave to the lender and you
are experiencing that i did too i
remember this feeling it makes me mad
just hearing about it again
it's a it gets you fired up doesn't it
oh yeah i mean it sounds like they've
got some leverage on you and i want you
to take some control back so be in in
communication with them and say hey
here's what i can do take it or leave it
i haven't paid this thing in three years
you could have seven grand today how's
that sound and i think they're gonna go
okay we'll take it they may not in the
first conversation they may they may
mess with you a little bit just go
listen when you decide you want some
money you call me in the meantime i'm
going to be sitting over here
waiting for your call
and hang up hang up the phone
okay you know
i would imagine he's being rude isn't he
yeah and he's not gonna take he seems
like he's not gonna take anything but
the twelves but
that's his great job don't believe that
crap it's it's just a job to him it's
not his money
yeah it's been really stressing me out
yesterday and by the way listen
his job is to put a check mark in the
box beside your name that's it
and he can't put a check mark in the box
beside your name until he gets some
money from you
so you got leverage over him he needs
the check mark
okay dude get some swagger right here
get some swagger back up
yeah this guy's you ever heard the
phrase gotcha buffaloed
you ever heard of that phrase no it's
got you scared
it means it's got you scared he's got
you cornered he's got you thinking he's
got you whipped and he hasn't got you
whipped he's just a duber in a cubicle
making phone calls and he needs a check
mark he works at a bank at one of the
worst jobs in the bank
it's a better job to clean septic tanks
than what he's doing
don't let him put you in the corner dude
throw your shoulders back step back up
into it punch him once and then hang up
the phone call me when you grow a brain
bozo hang up that's what you do
mess with them because that's their job
it's just a job it's not even a good job
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage joshua and jennifer are
with us hey guys how are you we're great
hello dave welcome welcome where do you
all live green castle pennsylvania all
right welcome to nashville and all the
way down here to do a debt-free scream
how much have you paid off 63 000 in
about 15 months all right and your range
of income during that time 158 to 156.
we're in that small amount that went
down just a little bit because of covid
ah okay
all right cool what do y'all do for a
living i'm a dental hygienist engineer
ah so dental hygienist was tough during
coping it was tough there was no way to
work right yeah very difficult are you
all back to work now we are we were only
out for about three months okay well
that's good yeah that's good news wow
what kind of debt was the 63 000
home equity and a car loan ah
okay
what'd you buy with a home equity loan
well new kitchen
counter tops
basically we went sought financial
advice
and we were told everyone has a car
payment
and you always should use your home
equity where'd you go the bank the bank
yeah yeah don't ask the bank if you need
to borrow money it's like asking a dog
if it's hungry oh my gosh way to go guys
all right that's fine so what happened
15 months ago that made you change your
direction
we would month to month we would do
things go out have fun and we never had
any extra money and every month i would
listen to him kind of complain you know
we make too much money to not have
anything yeah and it just hit me one day
we need to do something about this and i
finally got him on board it was really
hard being an engineer he's really good
with money numbers type thing
he's a geek he didn't think he really
needed help
convinced him to watch financial peace
university with me oh wow it was hard
but he did it it's about a 12 year
journey i read the book 12 years ago and
took some commit persuading ah okay but
i didn't give up and you know i want
other people to know too not to give up
you know just
make little comments here there and if
it's meant to be it'll happen and it did
happen and he listened and he was
totally on board wow sometimes the pokes
aren't so subtle but
we pick up on them
eventually yeah
so what what finally happened that made
you go
okay i'm gonna watch
i'd say she was very persistent
and then like she said i love to have
toys we get i had a mercedes i enjoyed
it and then we had kids and they didn't
fit car seats so
many years of uh
being
the good spouse or trying to do things
correctly get point-blank getting pissed
that everyone else has new vehicles they
get to do cool stuff
and we're two to three thousand dollars
a month on credit cards never missed a
payment never paid interest
but nothing to show for it at the end of
it not never a sense of of traction no
no living month to month i get paid one
time a month it's like
it's spent before i even get it oh yeah
yeah yeah and then the best part for us
was
we went and got a new car
and we got a really good deal on of
course
but they ran our credit score they
didn't even bother bothered to run gens
because she's like the guys like i've
seen five people have a credit score as
high as yours is almost perfect
so we know what that means now
we're really good friends of debt
collectors
oh my gosh
that is cool so you have this i love
debt score and you realize oh this is
not what winning looks like we've got to
do things differently i think we watched
fpu probably three or four times and
that chain episode in the first really
got to me
so you've known this stuff for a decade
but it had it took a while to get
through your hard head it sounds like
you read the book first and then i i
find
financial peace university online i
don't even remember how i came across it
but
we both started with the book and we
were really into it and then we never
really did anything with it but
financial business university was recent
that's why that was yes that's when you
got in gear 15 months ago yes okay good
all right way to go guys
okay so now you're the other side of
this with all the
uh
gyration and the emotions and everything
else and you fought your way really fast
through 65 000 once you decide to do it
it was game on
um and the numbers indicate that so now
what is your advice to someone that's
listening that's going i don't know if i
need to do this or not i don't know if
it'll work or not what do you i mean
what is the key that you picked up that
changed what broke you loose what was
the breakthrough the principle
the financial freedom once we didn't
have those payments anymore and we saw
all this money that was actually coming
into us
and we realized what we could do in the
future it was a total game changer
it was it was incredible because we we
made a plan the end of 2019 we're like
that's it we're doing this
we got some things we started really
saving for the kids college it's like
we're just not going to get there
so
december 2019 we printed out the baby
steps one through seven posted right
beside our computer and we started
marking off each one
january 2020 we hit the hit the ground
running and then covet hit yeah here
comes march yep
so during the whole time we're listening
to you
we're like four walls just worried about
four walls so we started continue to
paying on the car payment but then any
extra
after the car was paid off which was
april we just put it in the bank
and then even when we went to uh pay off
the home equity on april 1st of this
year
we took him a check for 12 000
that was the rest of the home equity
we're sitting in the drive-through
because the lobby's closed like oh by
the way you have 86 closing costs i'm
like we just called the guy yesterday
and he said this is it
so every time we're trying to pay stuff
off there's always this little
caveat clause hey you owe more money
it's like
you can't get rid of them no
so i want to walk away after i pay for
something not think twice about it yeah
yeah wow
way to go guys way to go how does it
feel now that you're free
wonderful it's just a feeling i never
thought i would feel i never thought
we'd get i mean i knew we would get
there but when you're starting and you
feel kind of hopeless like looking at
this big amount of money to pay off
you're like i'm it's going to take
forever but once you really get gazelle
intense and get into it
it's a great feeling
we even had some motivation along the
way so
february of this year we also took a
church class they were doing fpu at
church
we know the people facilitated one of
the things was cutting up the credit
cards right away it was like the second
week of class
we still had credit cards
we just couldn't let it go it was like
the sense of it you almost couldn't it
was one really we just couldn't let it
go just in case you did i don't know
there's a little security thing just in
case what it what if what happens so
what happened when you clipped the
security in half
we had the kids do it we made the kids
do it as a memory for them to not ever
do that and don't ever take a credit
card out and
um it felt great it felt liberating yeah
it wasn't as scary as you thought it
wasn't like oh i'm living without it
yeah it was not
yeah i was more concerned with kids
cutting themselves than the actual
friend
seriously
that's fun all right you brought them
with you what are their names and ages
alex and adam and they're nine and 11.
all right very cool good stuff well way
to go you guys we're very proud of you
we've got a copy of the total money
makeover for you to give away to
somebody else hopefully they'll read it
and do it uh and we've got a copy of the
legacy journey for you because that's
what you've done you've changed your
whole family tree congratulations you
guys very very well done so i got one
more thing for you then dave so okay as
we're coming down here who's looking all
over finances real quick and we just
looked at all of our retirements roth
iras the equity in our house and then we
realized oh my god we got 950 000
already and then if we look at our three
vehicles which are
two really old ones plus some jewelry
we're just over two thousand over a
million it's like wow we're almost there
everyday millionaires
incredible i love it that's awesome and
at the end of this month we're in baby
step four i love it well congratulations
you guys very well done joshua jennifer
alex and adam from pennsylvania 63 000
paid off in 15 months everyday
millionaires count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
we're dead
that's the way that happens whoa
i love it yes
this is the ramsey show
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
our scripture today second corinthians 1
4 he comforts us in all our troubles so
that we can comfort others
when they are troubled we will be able
to give them the same comfort god has
given us
william arthur ward said greatness is
not found in possessions power position
or prestige it is discovered in goodness
humility service and character
amen
open phones here at triple eight eight
two five five two two five george
campbell ramsey personality is my
co-host today
you jump in and we'll talk jennifer is
with us in pittsburgh hi jennifer
welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
well um so my grandmother passed away
like a year or so ago and then um my mom
just passed away like two weeks ago
well my mom
was drinking and they were estranged and
anyhow the grandmother left us
house and there was no will
and
i'm in pittsburgh now i live in
colorado but i'm in pittsburgh now
trying to deal with the mess
and the house was she was a bit of a
hoarder she was a heavy smoker she died
in the house in the home this is my
grandmother i'm talking about my mother
and
so
i called a few realtors and had them
come and they decided to get on an
inspector to look at the house
the inspector says that there's a bad
roof leak from the chimney
and that the foundation is really bad
there's gaps around the exterior some
walls need to be torn down
the slab is cracked yeah let's let's
stop let's stop a second okay
is there any debt on this estate
no
okay so your grandmother didn't have any
debt
no did she have any errors did she have
any children other than your mother
no
did your mother have any children other
than you
yes my brother but he wants no part of
any of it it doesn't it doesn't matter
what he wants there's no will
okay all right so
you and your brother are likely the
heirs you'll have to get a court order
in probate court in order to sell the
house
and the judge will take the proceeds
and tell you what to do with them which
would be to spread them to you and your
brother
if he doesn't want the check you can you
can take it at that point but um
yeah you don't need to get in a home
repair deal here that i would sell this
piece of garbage house like it is
as is that was my question yeah my
question was do i do that through a
realtor or do i do it alone i'm just
afraid i don't want to get
um you need to get a real estate you
need to get a real estate agent but you
need to get one that's up for the task
not all real estate agents know how to
sell something that's just trashed they
need an investor or two in their pocket
because you're going to sell this at
wholesale and below
okay so you do recommend absolutely
using a realtor and not doing it on my
own absolutely you have no idea what
you're doing
okay all right fair enough that was my
name what would you what would you guess
the house is worth
if it was all fixed if it was all fixed
up and nice just give me a guess
um well it's in a
really small town with lots of mobile
homes and not um this is a really old
home so i would say a hundred thousand
or less yeah so if you could get 54 it'd
be a great day
i i agree cash
yeah cash
you need a real estate agent you can
jump on
ramseysolutions.com and click on elp for
endorse local provider for real estate
agents talk to two or three of them in
that immediate area
ask them for some help see if one of
them just say i've i talked to dave i've
got an investor property i'm not doing
any work to it i'm gonna sell it as is
where is i'm gonna make somebody a deal
do you wanna do a quick
deal okay i can do that can i ask a
second question
okay sure
all right so as i said my grandmother
passed away in the house um like over a
year ago and then my mom
she she was a drinker and she ended up
dying from that in the hospital a few
weeks ago a couple weeks ago
and um so
i'm not one of those people that have
the grief clouding i've been dealing
with this my whole life so
my question is my mom started to try to
get a lawyer
to to try to get the money but she was
never sober enough to do it so it's
never been signed but there is a lawyer
there willing to work with me
my question would be since my mother
never owned my grandmother's house can
they come after me
for my mother's medical bills if i get
any money from this estate
you'd have to ask a lawyer that
in that state where she passed away i
don't know this is the problem with not
having a will
and you know the estate is liable
for the estate's bills your mother
inherited the house but she never really
inherited it because the the transaction
was never completed
and so it probably passes directly to
you and bypasses her medical bills but
i'm not a lawyer in pennsylvania in
minnesota so i can't tell you for sure
but since your mother never took
possession of the property legally
through the courts
never then it would never stand for her
medical bills that's my theory
but my theory's worth exactly what you
paid for it
so you probably ought to contact an
attorney as well
because you're going to have to run this
through probate and the judge can tell
you when you run through probate you're
going to have to get a court order in
order to sign the deed
you can't just go i'm the heir because
the title company will not accept that
and the deed is not valid when you sign
it without a court order so you have to
get a probate probate court is where
wills and estates are handled and you
have to get uh you will have to spend
some money on that but i would do that
as a part of the sale
and uh then i would get in the car and
go back to colorado
and let the real estate agent and the
lawyer handle this from long distance
and you go back to work and don't spend
any more of your emotional or time
bandwidth on this don't clean out a
hoarder's house
it's one of the most grotesque possible
things you can ever have to do it's
gross
just gross
oh
all right up next is jennifer and
jennifer's in pittsburgh wait a minute
so is that anyone i was talking to
we're going to leah oh minneapolis got
too many things i got leah
got all kinds of things
kelly helped me out here there it is
leah hey leah in minneapolis same
question almost right you're almost the
same question that's one game i have to
tell you how thankful i am for you
my dad got a total money makeover to my
high school class and i've never had a
penny of debt
all because of you wow thankful good for
you
um yeah it's not a similar question um
my grandmother passed away uh
a year ago
and her house is in the middle of
nowhere on a farm in minnesota where
we're from and i have such a strong
nostalgic connection to it um
and i'm i'm all the way down at step six
of our plants i've never had debt i've
got my smart investor i've got my full
emergency fund
and i'm ready to
find myself a house
and i just
i'm so connected to that farm that i'm
toying with the idea of
taking it over but it needs a full
renovation um
the thing about being in the middle of
nowhere is there's no return on that
investment like nobody's going to buy
that house from me for what i would put
into it so i'm wondering what you think
of that with the financial situation
i appreciate your heart
and
the older i get the more nostalgic i get
about things
but this is not an investment in real
estate this is an investment in romance
of the past
sure i understand that
and that would make it usually a really
crummy investment
yeah i see that
you know i i it kind of breaks your
heart to say that out loud
but um i mean i think of my
grandmother's farm it was out in the
middle of nowhere in missouri and of
course it was sold off when she passed
away many many many moons ago
but um
you know and the old house was torn down
now they farm over the whole thing it's
big you know it's out in the middle of
that flat lands it's just big crops of
big big rows of corn or rows of soybeans
right through where she used to live and
it kind of hurts your heart a little bit
you know
but it also
it's just the drum beat of life i mean
there's a journey we're on here and it's
uh you're not taking anything with you
that's why there's no rider trucks
following hearses
so if i'm you i'm selling that i'm not
investing in romance yeah i think you
you let it be a sweet memory and you
honor that and you grieve what you're
losing here but leah it sounds like
you've got big dreams for your life and
and you want to build and live this life
and i don't want you building this big
old thing in the middle of nowhere i
think you need to live your dreams and
let it be a sweet memory yeah
that puts us hour the ramsey show in the
books we'll be back with you before you
know it in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk daily with the
prince of peace christ jesus
[Music]
did you know you can listen to the
ramsay show on your smart speaker just
tell alexa google assistant or siri to
play the ramsay show podcast
check out all ramsay network shows on
your smart speaker today
[Music]
you